[Music]
it's october
and you know what time it is halloween
so for this week let's go through some
of the best spooky halloween hits in
and no you know what forget it yeah
instead of doing something about spooky
things i prefer to get you going with an
adrenaline rush so for this edition of
vinnie tube lists we won't be talking
about the top horror anime that you can
watch for halloween
instead we'll be going over some of the
best action shows with a dash of horror
and mind screw
are you ready for this challenge let's
get going but before we go i noticed
that not all of my watches are sub to
this channel
it would make me really happy if you
would hit that sub button and help this
channel continue growing before starting
the video
okay i'm done let's start for real now
[Music]
number 10 on the list is blood plus this
is one of the shows that anime fans of
my generation would have probably heard
of in their teen
years blood plus is about sire seemingly
your ordinary girl
plus the anemia and amnesia who gets
attacked by a chiropteran
bat like humanoid monsters luckily for
her [ __ ] comes to the rescue and lets
her drink his blood awakening powers
within her
and turning her into a monster killing
machine pecuniarities continue occurring
around her and she soon learns of red
shield a secret organization founded for
the sake of dealing with those beasts
after all these years i'm honestly not
sure how well blood plus his premise and
plot would have aged
which is why i placed it pretty low on
this list however it remains one of my
teen favorites
and i think that it helped ease me into
a lot of shows in this genre
if you're up for a quick monster slaying
fix with some badass characters do check
this one out
the 50 episodes are definitely worth it
we move on with high school of the dead
at number nine
coming off the zombie craze at the start
of the previous decade
do you remember that this is our next
entry fan service galore
a lot of blood and loads and loads of
zombies sums up high school of the dead
pretty well
in high school of the dead japan gets
thrown into total chaos overnight with
the start of a zombie apocalypse as the
school gets overrun
our protagonist takashi is forced to
escape with rey the girlfriend of his
friend that he had to unfortunately
execute
what awaits them outside is a society
that's been taken over by the living
dead
thankfully they have allies on their
side joining them is a band of other
student survivors but will their ragtag
group have what it takes to survive this
nightmare one look at the opening and
the poster can pretty much give you an
idea of what to expect now as i said
before the show
is fan service galore but it's also
filled with some nice
action sequences and a genuinely
interesting setting and world it can be
quite mindless in its approach in how it
throws guns and fan service at you but
if you're someone who's in for those
this show will definitely tickle your
fancy
[Applause]
next up is a movie from the year 2000
vampire hunter d
bloodlust if you know it got a movie at
the start of the millennium
and it didn't disappoint the story
revolves around the titular d
a renowned vampire hunter born of the
holy union between
vampire and human his next task has him
on a rescue mission to save the young
noblewoman
charlotte elborn the bounty for his task
is huge and the hunt is on
even with mysterious forces acting in
the background this rescue mission also
seems to be more than it looks at first
glance and perhaps
d has accepted a quest that even a
hunter like him can't handle
vampire hunter d bloodlust is a gripping
movie and i found myself enjoying
every single bit of it now at first
glance it gave me some van helsing and
castlevania vibes i'd say that my first
impressions aren't that far off actually
but the movie still has its unique
points especially in the character
development that gets done in such a
short plot not to mention how good its
animation is for the time it was
released
it has a good blend of suspense and
action and you might want to watch this
for your halloween movie fix seventh in
line is
[Applause]
arjin
super powered beings living alongside
regular humans has been a recurring
theme in anime or media in general for
that matter oftentimes they come into
conflict with the more mundane and
ordinary residents of the world and
those conflicts can end up being quite
brutal
arjun brings us to that world where
after getting run over by a truck hey
instead of waking up in another world
awakes as an arjun the problem arjin
have high bounties over their heads and
kay finds himself being betrayed by all
that he knew with the exception
of his lone friend together the two make
a run for it and come in contact with a
hidden society of ajim however it turns
out that arjun aren't really the nicest
people around especially after years of
abuse and being ostracized giving me
some serious tokyo ghoul vibes here
arjun for
me is quite the nice dark fantasy story
that presents an interesting battle of
ideals it's got some cool social
commentary that you can take note of
sprinkled atop the narrative that's
filled to the brim with action
and suspense next is a cult classic
elfin lead
[Music]
one of the often talked about classics
is elf and lead correct me if i'm wrong
but this
is one anime that often appears in
random recommendations but
for good reason too elfin lead talks of
lucy a special breed of human who
escapes from a research facility during
the breakout she gets shot and gets left
with a split personality later two
university students stumble upon her and
decide to take her home
however trouble pursues the students as
they have to deal with not only
government agencies going after lucy but
of their new companions traumatic past
and
dark split personality when it comes to
elf and lead there are lots of things to
like about it you could say that it's a
show with ample doses of mutant action
split personalities nudity sudden mood
swings and loads and loads of gore
yes this is a show that would have been
censored to hell and back under today's
standards but
it's one of the most enduring action
horror shows in anime history and for
good reason too
we continue with an oldie but goodie
akira
ah akira the anime movie that's long
been credited as the one that brought
anime past the borders of japan and into
the west one of the pioneers of anime
akira still holds up quite well today
set in a tokyo that's been rebuilt from
the ashes of a third world war akira
puts us in a city rife with crime and
corruption
caught in a battle between biker gangs a
youth named tetsuo gets taken into
custody along with one of the people
seen
exhibiting super powers as things would
have it tetsuo's power was also awakened
and it drives him
insane leading him to break away from
the lab in a war path it's up to his
friend garneta to stop him one of the
most controversial and beloved anime
movies to have ever been made akira is a
movie that delves into
psychology sci-fi and horror it's one of
those
overly violent titles that aren't for
the faint of heart but it provides its
fair share of bloodbath
overall akira gives the complete
experience that would surely enrich
anyone watching it and hey it did
convince people decades ago that anime
is a medium to be taken seriously
up for some more vampire action well
we've got one more for this list and i
saved the best for last
in great britain there exists an
organization that protects people from
monsters that prey upon people
the organization aptly named helsing is
led by integra
and his star operative the vampire
alucard standing against them is the
rival organization
the catholic church and the enigmatic
father anderson
caught in all of this is a survivor of a
police squad who becomes a vampire
herself
and joining helsing the organization
uncovers a plot of apocalyptic
proportions that threatens the world
amazing animation great fights
unrelenting violence
some of the best showcases of powers in
anime
what more could you ask for in a fantasy
horror series helsing is one of the most
popular series of the genre it's
something better watched than red
so go ahead and start watching it now
standing in our runner-up spot in second
place is berserk
when it comes to horror and unrestrained
violence i find few shows capable of
holding a candle to berserk in that
regard of course i'm talking about the
1997 berserk not the recent one that had
its fair share of online popcorn berserk
is the story of
guts an orphan who embraces the
battlefield
fighting for his life day after day his
life takes a huge turn after his run-in
with the band of the hawk a mercenary
group led by the charismatic griffith
joining the group as a formidable new
ally gutz quickly realizes the world
isn't as simple as he thought it was
after all bloodshed and strength aren't
everything in this grim world what more
needs to be said about berserk starring
one of the most
badass and outright brutal protagonists
out there there is a reason
why the series has become a classic that
stood the test of time do take note
though the anime does have some heavy
modifications in order to tone down the
violence but i think
it's a decent adaptation overall unlike
the latest one
topping off yet another list is parasite
[Applause]
i think when it comes to combining
action and its signature style of body
horror few titles can come close to
parasite for those of you who don't know
about the series parasite is basically a
show about an alien invasion only this
time they don't come
in spaceships or look like those green
or grey men we've come to know aliens
for instead these
organisms come in the form of parasites
that latch onto humans and possess them
turning them into transformative
monsters with an appetite
for human flesh thankfully our
protagonist shinichi was able to stop a
hostile takeover but in exchange
said parasite gets stuck in his hand the
parasite called migi comes to life as
his transforming hand and the duo gets
forced to put aside their differences in
order to survive the crapsack world
where fellow parasites are on the hunt
for them combining
philosophical themes some serious
violence high octane action
and some really funky music parasite is
probably one of the shows that i'd
eagerly blindly recommend to someone who
hasn't watched anime at all i think that
after all of these years
the original story from the manga that's
over three decades old
still holds up strongly definitely put
this on your watch list
if you want to watch some action horror
anime
well i guess that's more than enough
anime for you to enjoy in the upcoming
halloween week
which ones are you most excited about
which ones have you already seen
and how did you find them please share
your thoughts and sentiments down in the
comment section below and we can have
fun chatting about anime and other cool
things too
now before i end the video i'd like to
give a shout out to the sponsors of this
video
lazy moods they offer a variety of these
amazing lamps from anime like naruto
hunter hunter attack on titan and loads
more each led lamp has a variety of
colors and is remote controlled
currently they're offering 50 discount
plus free shipping
which is ending soon so make sure you
don't miss it you can also use my code
vinnie for an additional 10 discount my
personal favorite one is the attack on
titan lamp but i also love this thousand
sunny one i mean just look how
incredible these look this is something
really unique so make sure you check it
out the links in the description before
i go i'd like to once again
encourage you to subscribe and hit the
bell button on your way out
it would really mean so much to me
thanks for all of the love and support
you've been giving me recently
and i'll see you next time